step one will happen from the 8th of
march
by which time those in the top four
priority groups will be benefiting
from the increased protection they
receive from their first dose
of the vaccine mr speaker all the
evidence shows
that classrooms are the best places for
our young people to be
and that's why i've always said that
schools would be the last to close
and the first to reopen
and based on our assessment of the
current data against the four
tests i can tell the house that two
weeks
from today pupils and students in all
schools
and further education settings can
safely return
to face-to-face teaching supported by
twice weekly testing
of secondary school and college pupils
families and child care bubbles will
also be encouraged to get tested
regularly
breakfast and after school clubs can
also reopen and other children's
activities including sport
can restart where necessary to help
parents to work students on university
courses requiring practical teaching
specialist facilities or on-site
assessments
will also return but all others will
need to continue learning online
and we will review the options for when
they can return
by the end of the easter holidays
from the 8th of march people will also
be able to meet one
person from outside their household for
outdoor recreation
such as a coffee on a bench or a picnic
in a park
in addition to exercise
but we're advising the clinically
extremely vulnerable to shield
at least until the end of march
every care home resident will be able to
nominate a named
visitor able to see them regularly
provided
they are tested and wear ppe and finally
we will amend regulations to enable a
broader
range of coveted secure campaign
activities for local elections
on the 6th of may as part of step one
we will go further and make limited
changes on 29th of march
when schools go on easter holidays
it will become possible to meet in
limited numbers outdoors where the risk
is lower so the rule of six will return
outdoors including in private gardens
and outdoor meetings of two households
will also be permitted
on the same basis so that families in
different circumstances
can meet outdoor sports facilities such
as tennis
and basketball courts and open-air
swimming pools
will be able to reopen and formally
organized outdoor sports will resume
subject to guidance from this point 29th
of march
people will no longer be legally
required
to stay at home but many lockdown
restrictions
will remain people should continue to
work from home where they can
and minimize all travel wherever
possible
step two will begin at least five weeks
after the beginning
of step one and no earlier than the 12th
of april
with an announcement at least seven days
in advance if analysis of the latest
data against the four tests
requires a delay then this and
subsequent steps
will also be delayed to maintain
the five-week gap in step two
non-essential retail will reopen as will
personal care including
hairdressers i'm glad to say and nail
salons
indoor leisure facilities such as gyms
will reopen as will holiday let's but
only if you're used by individuals
or household groups we will begin to
reopen our pubs
and restaurants outdoors and honourable
members will be relieved
there will be no curfew and the scotch
egg debate will be over because there
will be no requirement
for alcohol to be accompanied by a
substantial meal
zoos theme parks and drive-in cinemas
will reopen as will public libraries
and community centers step 3 will begin
no earlier than the 17th of may
provided the data satisfies the four
tests most restrictions on meetings
outdoors will be lifted subject to a
limit of 30
and this is the point when you will be
able to see your friends and family
indoors subject to the rule six or the
meeting of two households we will also
reopen pubs and restaurants indoors
along with cinemas and children's play
areas
hotels hostels and bnbs
theaters and concert halls will reopen
their doors
and the turnstiles of our sports stadia
will once again
rotate subject in all cases to capacity
limits
depending on the size of the venue and
we will pilot
larger events using enhanced testing
with the ambition of further easing of
restrictions
in the next step step 4
will begin no earlier than the 21st of
june
with appropriate mitigations we will aim
to remove
all legal limits on social contact
and on weddings and other life events we
will reopen
everything up to and including
nightclubs
and enable large events such as theater
performances
above the limits of step 3 potentially
using testing to reduce the risk of
infection